uh we sure do no penalty flags here for
the weather so far this morning except
it is a little cloudy out there you can
see that snow glowing up there in the
spring mountains the sun will be up here
in just about five minutes or so but
it's going to struggle against those
clouds this morning lots of 40s around
the las vegas valley a couple of spots
in the 30s nellis seven hills red rock
at 37 and just above freezing up there
at kyle canyon here are your headlines
as we roll into a new week morning
clouds and then we should see a little
more afternoon sunshine temperatures in
the low 60s today a system that's
pushing clouds our way right now is
going to move inland tonight into
southern california and through the
desert might actually bring a slight
chance of some showers through the
desert overnight into early tomorrow
morning then that system will be gone
and we should have really a nice sunny
rest of the week lots of good sunshine
and mid 60s from wednesday on let's get
to the east coast though and this big
winter storm that's blasting
up the east coast in the interior
northeast as well as the ohio valley
over a foot of snow has already dropped
in the appalachians this storm should
reach its finale later today but winter
storm warnings places like erie pa oh
man is it cold there this morning it's
28 degrees with colder wind chills that
feel like the low 20s sometimes teens
you can see these cameras rocking around
out there looking at snow for the rest
of the day into tonight and again there
are
not only winter storm warnings for the
interior parts of the northeast but also
along the coast they've got wind
advisories flood advisories because most
of this is rain this storm even brought
tornadoes to southwest florida yesterday
morning but it's going to roll up into
southeast canada at the end of the day
and then it'll be done all right so
we've got this system off the coast of
southern california again it's got some
moisture with it so as it moves in
dew points will rise and we will see
some scattered showers across the desert
tonight into early tuesday morning so
for your mlk parade plans this morning
just dress warm temperatures will be
right around 50 51 degrees this morning
so it is going to be chilly down there
not a whole lot of sun to warm you up
either more sunshine this afternoon that
slight chance of showers overnight and
tuesday morning and then after that
system rolls out the rest of the week is
easy wow mid 60s we should be at around
59 for the high we should beat that
every day for the week